intermission report a 0-0 game after one
period in chicago now earlier this
evening the blackhawks held a town hall
meeting to discuss the future of the
organization and the search for a new
permanent gm the panel consisted of
chairman rocky wertz ceo danny wertz and
president of business ops jamie faulkner
eddie altrick moderated fans were
present so were members of the medium
and as you might expect questions about
how exactly the team is moving forward
following the kyle beach lawsuit were
asked
i think much of what happened to kyle
beach stem from a a power imbalance
between a coach and a player and the
powerlessness of a player in that
situation
so what are the blackhawks doing what
have the blackhawks done what will the
blackhawks do to empower a player in a
similar situation to make sure that
doesn't happen again i'm going to answer
the question at the end
i think the report speaks for itself
the people that were involved are no
longer here
we're not looking back in 2010 we're
looking forward
and we're not going to talk about 2010.
i know and i'm not either and we're not
going to talk about what happened we're
moving forward that is my answer now
what's your next question i can pick up
to what we are doing today and i think
no i don't know that's none of your
business
that's done your business what we're
going to do today is our business
i don't think it's any of your business
because i don't think it's in your
business you don't work for the company
if someone in the company asks that
question we'll answer it
and i think you should get on to the
next subject
we're not going to talk about kyle beach
we're not going to talk about anything
that happened now we're moving on what
more do i have to say you want to keep
asking the same question do you hear the
same answer
okay ask the next question
that was a question asked by mark
lazarus of the athletic a similar
question was posed later and rocky words
essentially just doubled down i mean
it's stunning uh and it's beyond
disappointing
to sit there and say in a matter of this
serious that you're done with it we're
not talking about it anymore that's it
we're moving on and we don't have to
share this information i would have
liked to have heard what their plan is
and you saw danny try to jump in there
and we were talking off-camera about
this i wish danny would have jumped in
and you know protected his dad and said
hey dad i got this i'm now the new ceo
i'm the guy leading this operation going
forward i'd like to hear from him and
hear exactly what him and jamie faulkner
and their president of business
operation would have to say
he obviously came in like we talked
about gretz off-camera too and talked
that he had a bone to pick with that
writer going in so it didn't matter what
he said the writer came and said hey
guess what talk you got a great jacket
on yeah you would still have that same
reaction you make mistakes what do you
do you talk about them and then you do
things about it like you can't hide it
and and
i'm a coach you know i used to be a
coach like i want to know maybe there's
ways of hey what would i do different or
as an assistant coach if these things
happen that's what you want to hear is
there protocols to do it so yeah i i
don't know if rocky i think he just he
was upset about something else and he
just kept going um i would love to send
danny to have this is what we're doing i
think that would have been the positive
spin it's a little disappointed how that
went down
and i would think you know as a player
you know if you're impartial you're not
a blackhawks player but you're watching
this i mean you want a team that's
willing to share that information and
talk about it listen from every point of
view this is just
a horrible scenario horrible situation
what happened to that young man
but i'm sitting here thinking that as a
parent you're sitting there going my
son's 18 years old he's going to maybe
be drafted by that team i i want to make
sure yeah and i'm sure they do have
things in place that are going to
protect those kids moving forward
but obviously as you said ace there was
some
illness between the two before that
meeting meeting even started but i mean
yeah the bottom line is first of all i
like to point out it's a town hall
setting the idea is to share this
information with fans and people in the
organization people outside the
organization if you have a plan in place
like that where you can empower players
to make sure this doesn't happen it just
boggles my mind why would you not want
to